[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another episode of honest trailer
commentaries commentaries commentaries
today's episode is about kung fu panda
we'll watch a trailer together give you
our behind the scenes thoughts we'll
watch some cut jokes
we will respond to questions and
comments from viewers like yourselves
then we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer
but get it right this time sorry we
missed that uh it was a little off in
the script
last time so uh pretend last week's
tease
was for next week's teas and this week's
teas
will be the teas that i would have given
you for kung fu panda hello
why are you doing this to yourself you
don't have to torture yourself
i'm sorry i'm just like i i'm i fully
ron burgundy the script because i should
have known that like we hadn't even done
what we're doing next week at that point
but i just read the words in front of me
i was excited to
go eat lunch hi danielle how's it going
hi it's going good i do that all the
time with teleprompter stuff as well
we do this live baby we're doing it live
no cuts um
uh what did you think of kung fu panda a
film that i had never seen before
yeah i was uh i hadn't seen it either
and i was super prepared to hate it and
be like uh dreamworks
you know what it was cute and a lot of
parts and it's also like
i will say the action for a cartoon was
actually
really good um easy to follow it was fun
you all know me uh you get people kick
or anthropomorphic animals kicking other
anthropomorphic animals in the face
danielle's gonna want to be there for
that that's fine
it's like it's it's definitely not cool
to
um make slash watch uh
animals fight each other in real life
but this movie does a great job at
showing you what it would look like
if you taught animals martial arts and
made them fight each other in real life
like the fact that they based
the furious five on like actual the five
different animal styles of kung fu
and thought like not like the p how do
people look imitating those animals but
how would those animals actually fight
each other
the fight scenes were awesome in this
movie yeah and very well animated which
i don't really associate with dreamworks
i think of them as being like
budget pixar or like like joke delivery
vehicles like
like shrek or uh are they ants or a
bug's life whatever that whatever the rc
the rc cola version don't quote me
maybe yeah pick your uh
pick whichever one was yeah so i too was
was kind of blown away
and i i guess it's crazy that i'd never
watch this because like you pointed out
there's a million of these
there's there's two sequels and like and
like five other franchise
pieces there's like they have their own
land in
they have a kung fu panda land where you
go it's like a big theme park
which is like one of those things we
always joke about is movie being theme
park this one actually is
and yeah it was so popular that they got
all of these different they were able to
basically make money through everything
i'm surprised i have not eaten
you know kung fu panda uh noodles or
something like that like i'm surprised
that that never happened
totally um because and you know what if
they make another one they sure will
because people love noodles man
noodles featured uh there were
plot-centric noodles there were there
were a lot of nudes in this movie
um i promise you that throughout today's
episode i will be asking a lot of
questions
that have been answered in one of those
many offshoots
and probably annoying the the big panda
heads in the audience who are like
actually they answer that in episode
seven of uh kung fu pan of the series
part nine
so i apologize in advance um but i have
questions like
are they all vegetarians or are some of
the animals they live amongst
like fodder for dumplings oh
is that why he comes he's just like a
big butcher the bad guy he just comes to
like get all the pork and then bail i
don't know i mean i think that uh
they had the the weird quasi uh uh
eugenics movie known as zootopia was
like oh we uh we bred the
the meat eating out of the carnivores
they naturally would eat other animals
but
uh you know we've civilized them
i feel like this movie just kind of
dodges it but also when i was thinking
like
oh this is a this like chinese food
plays a big role in this like
chinese food is like pork heavy um lots
of pork and lots of pigs running around
that land
it's uh just just food for thought uh
i'm sure i'll have many questions more
like that
as we watch the trailer for kung fu
panda
let's go
if you can't choose between spending 30
bucks on ryan the last dragon
or groceries but your kids are still too
dumb for seoul
why not try kung fu
i mean off panda but 30 bucks for ryan
you doing it this weekend
uh absolutely not no and i want it i
want to see it i just don't
it'll come i'll wind up i might wind up
paying the 30 bucks for it but 30 bucks
is like so steep it'd be different if i
had
like a bunch of kids and we were all
gonna sit down and you make your own
food and it's really fun
that's who that 30 price tag is for us
for families i have
me and i have two cats and so far the
cats have never shown a preference
for movies or me so i
probably will not be spending the 30
bucks well as you guys say if you told
your cats that they're not part of your
family apparently you don't consider
them family
uh it's really the other way around
chief
they have let me know you have no
interest
yeah yeah uh all right keep going i
won't go off on catch today they uh
prepared a solid mid-level animated
movie for when you just can't handle
another viewing of shark tale
yo yo yo yo
and enjoy the entry point into a
franchise that spawned two sequels
five shorts eight video games two
animated series
and a theme park land because china
because china experience
um i read an article just doing research
about this movie that was like
kung fu panda spawned like an identity
crisis in the chinese film industry
where chinese filmmakers were like why
can we not make a movie as good as
as kung fu panda why did it take america
to
to make the ultimate chinese movie and
it's like oh
no i'm so sorry it was cool and it
yeah it is like really well first of all
it was many years ago
um and i they were framing it in the
terms of like uh
there's so much government control over
what we can and can't make we keep
getting notes from
you know different communist party
leaders on on our films
but like you know free of those
constraints we could be making movies
like kung fu panda
which to me is like funny because it
seems like the product of the most
kind of cynical american movie
filmmaking where it's like that's a
funny title i think kids would buy that
on lunchbox
and it it's like against that system
that it turned out to be any good at all
um but yeah just uh just interesting the
different perspectives
i also do think that this is like a
movie that definitely translates well
um as like a foreign film because it's
not very dialogue driven it's all
physical comedy and
really cool fight scenes so yeah uh
making fun of fat people that's a global
thing everyone gets that
everyone gets fatty falls down
[Laughter]
that wonders can fat people do anything
of value
as this fat panda named poe is stuck
stuck
not what who maybe remind you is fat
and played by fat joke expert jack black
building the parachute
will inspire wall-to-wall fat jokes that
flabby panda can't possibly be the
answer to
our problem only to spend the last few
minutes proving that a fat guy can do
something other than cook and eat
stop it
okay i'm sorry but pandas are supposed
to be fat can you imagine a panda with
abs and a v line
gross or hot i'll have to look into that
laugh along with i mean
people are already posting in the
comments of where
the hottest pandas uh um i'm sorry what
we rank in campus
yes we are top 10 hottest pandas
um number four will shock you uh
yeah they um i i just think it's funny
to do the
the gradual uh kinkification of the epic
voice guy this has just been like a
like a meta narrative throughout honest
trailers of like his
his the the staleness of his marriage
and the weirdness uh
not the weirdness but the the new
avenues of
of interest that he's been exploring if
you go through like i don't know
the certainly the 50 shades trailers we
talk about it and we sprinkled it
throughout
is um not john bailey who's happily
married uh yeah but the character of
epic voice guy is constantly looking for
new and exotic ways to uh spice up his
life
i gave him a third nipple and i felt
very good about that
yeah i think if somebody compiled like
all the things we've revealed about
uh the epic voice guy like he has a very
chaotic existence yeah it's from he's
going through it
he's finding himself not his kids though
not his kids
definitely ignores his kids he's broke
and he's uh very
very sexually adventurous so yeah his
legend only grows because i think from
here on out he's gonna get into um
uh pandas with abs that'll be the only
way he can feel anymore
and they just call it add panda and now
we have a new series
on the cw okay keep going jack black
and all of his most beloved vocal tics
legend with authentic battle damage
then feast your ears on a buffet of
celebrity voice i mean just a moment on
on jack black uh i don't really know
what a uh
q score is i hear it talk about it it
has nothing to do with q and on i assume
but like
it just means like how popular or like
universally beloved someone is
jack black's gotta be up there right as
far as like
universal acceptance and like yeah
you're cool
yeah i think definitely if we're talking
modern-day people
um he's definitely in like top 20. that
man stays working and
he's still even with like when he does
his shtick even if it's old you're still
like
i can't stay mad at you jack black it's
like mad at you yeah
even if it's even if it's old like you
still they find different ways to do it
because in this one you know uh panda
that does kung fu in his next one it'll
be some other version of that
um well the the deuce is just fun to
hear and think skadoosh is an all-timer
the
his latest evolution is like he's a he's
become like a gaming youtuber
which i think is just an adorable
evolution of
of this man um and yeah he's kind of
covered all the bases because
for me like my introduction is like
tenacious deo it's like alt-edgy comedy
and then it's like oh we'll do
school of rock and he can do like these
great family films and then
um he went prestige with like bernie and
like he's he's done some
real acting um and then he did he did
his cash out phase with kung fu panda so
take the money and get that money enjoy
your life take the money
and run uh brentwood's own jack black
i promise i don't know what his real
name is but i promise you it's not jack
black
maybe it's caduceus that's why he puts
it in so often
yeah then feast your ears on the buffet
of celebrity voiceovers that kids won't
even care about
in fact does anyone really care that the
snake is voiced by lucy lou
i thought you said you were ready are
you super excited that this is dustin
hoffman grunting
and how much do you think jackie chan
got paid for this or you even see his
toes
but he will tigers you gotta try this
shifu we got this
help her he's too fast come little one
let's find your mama
that's every single line he has in the
entire movie
pause it's insane
how little not just jackie chan but
every
huge celebrity how little every
celebrity talks
yeah they're i don't think any one of
them has more than 10 lines yeah
and obviously it's like money well spent
i guess because the
this was a ginormous hit but at the same
time like
wow do you need angelina jolie to say 12
words
and then bounce i guess because you can
put her name on the poster right like
yeah is that why i i'm i'm guessing
because yeah like they're
cashing these huge checks for what is a
day's worth of work
maybe um guys it's a good life if you
can get it i swear
but um no like as we say in the trailer
like
no one really cares that that's lucy
like those aren't the names that
everyone was making on it was jack black
so yeah it is interesting that they
actually spent the money
and got some of the hottest people like
seth rogen they get him to do a laugh
and it's like well that was worth it
that's like
what a 250 000 laughs but they got it
yeah i guess so and seth rogen i guess
to his credit for is known for his voice
um but you know angelia jolie lucy lou
david cross like all fine actors i
couldn't
well dave across i guess i don't know i
just i don't think i know what angelina
jolie sounds like
if like four different you know vaguely
sultry ladies
said my name behind me and i couldn't
look at them i could not tell you which
one was angelina jolie
but it's for the kids or that's the part
that's for the adults where they're like
well we'll put angelina
jolie in it and then the adults will
care got it yeah
i guess beyond a game of like who's that
voice um
i thought i had misidentified dustin
hoffman i thought it was um
liam neeson or something like that some
other gravelly guy
uh but it but yeah so i guess it is it
keeps you interested you get to
think of what huge cameo is coming up
next who is the
who's the snow leopard oh ian mcshane
yeah he sounds great
he sounds amazing yeah yeah
all right keep going don't count unless
jackie did his own stunts too
you know what he probably did he's such
a pro
follow along on a standard hero's
journey where poe starts off as a
basement dwelling fanboy who studies the
blade
until destiny leads him to steal a
promotion from a more qualified woman
master are you pointing at me him
now under the tutelage of a ninja turtle
who talks like your aunt's facebook page
today is a gift that is why it is called
the present
the big panda will fight the big left uh
danielle you had a theory that this guy
is like completely bsing
master
i was going a little uh i was i was
watching the kung fu panda and i started
spiraling because i was like
nothing everything is that dude's fault
i don't remember his name right off the
top but everything was that dude's fault
because he was the one that said hey
uh tai long i believe is the name of the
the snow leopard uh
is about to escape you've gotta we've
gotta pick this dragon warrior we've
gotta do all that
he's only able to escape because that
messenger goes there and drops the
feather and then
he escapes and then he goes to pick the
dragon warrior as instead of picking the
chick that's like the obvious choice
he's like well my finger just ha he was
there when my finger pointed
well that's that's just science and
magic if you're in front of my finger
where i can't possibly
change it and then he just goes around
yeah he sounds exactly
like um i you know if you've got one of
those uh
daily uh exercise trackers it just
reminds you that like
you know every day you start at day zero
and be very
and have gratitude um that's what he
does but he doesn't really
he kind of the whole movie is his fault
well yeah
and and his catchphrase is there are no
accidents so
he's definitely kind of pulling the
strings behind this whole thing and then
he conveniently you know
does the luke skywalker you know jedi
fade away
yeah before before he can face his
consequences
hold that turtle accountable the cartoon
turtle must pay for his crowd
he and pepe lepew need to go to cartoon
prison together
with eric cartman bad bad cartoons bad
cartoons
oh okay keep going present the big panda
will fight the big leopard over who gets
to be the big dragon
and discover say it with me now that the
real magic was inside him all along
to make something special you just have
to believe it's special
being good at what you do but i'm
sure this is explored in the sequels in
fact i think i know it is
but they that's not his biological
dad right look i don't want to know the
science
about how that would happen i know that
we don't think about science for these
uh these cuddly cartoon characters the
physics alone i am
i am uninterested in figuring out
i am anti-interested
well well no we won't dive into it we
won't die see you can't help it
there's no way to ask the question
without getting into the weeds
yeah um well can goose how high can a
goose fly never mind
everybody special
that's the unofficial dreamworks motto
so enjoy the first film in a franchise
that's better than it has any right to
be
that may be a total pain by number story
but dang
that pain is super nice looking
so nice in fact that it skunked wally at
the annie awards causing disney to
boycott them for 10 years
yeah suck it trash robot
story tenacious chi
less cute than an actual red panda send
news
crap for the actual red panda thing i
think we were just worried about
um rights issues or something but uh we
found a video of two
uh red pandas like cuddle fighting and
it's maybe the cutest thing
that i've ever seen we were gonna just
show that instead of like
like i'd rather watch these red pandas
fight and it was oh man
i barely even knew they existed but wow
those are some cute animals
especially when two of them have beef or
are in love
i can't tell it's a complicated
relationship yeah
all right keep going an actual red panda
send nudes
crouching tiger hack the planet monken
master
animal david crossing deadly viper
assassination squad
ian mcgains and turtle super the soul
school of walk
okay why is everyone who's not a kung fu
master a pig a goose or a rabbit
did the animators just start hitting
copy paste
i mean maybe i think that they could
have probably saved
their budget because these don't have
the same budgets as uh as pixar disney
movies
um they do try to do things cheap which
by
stan at these standards is like a few
hundred million dollars less but still
in the six seven eight nine figures um
they probably saved it for uh for the
fight scenes like like any responsible
responsibly budgeted action movie will
do um
which is smart also that opening scene
where it's all like 2d animation is
gorgeous yeah i really like the the
style of this like the way they managed
to kind of split the
difference between like a hand-painted
style and
the cg 3d stuff it was more pleasing to
me than like
um than i guess a shrek or or something
where it is just fully
uh uh fully in that stuff in that style
but yeah
yeah um i wonder if they maintain this
quality throughout the rest of the kung
fu
panda franchise i think i'm going to
watch the rest of the kung fu panda
movies voluntarily it's crazy
yeah it's like 90 minutes it's a smooth
quarantine you got some time
it seems like a nice a nice breezy watch
you get jack black goofing around and
some panda puns and then some animal
fights maybe angelina jolie will say
more than five lines that could be cool
who cares um let's see what should we do
at this point oh let's uh let's thank
you guys for watching this
uh this far uh please subscribe to
phantom entertainment if you haven't
hit that like hit that bell don't be a
ding-dong hit the bell
uh and you will get reminded every time
we make another one of these dumb videos
um speaking of dumb stuff let's see what
we cut
out of this trailer roll it
staring jack black and white
tenacious p samurai jack black
hoe enough patience my young one
master splinter soup dreams
tiger uppercut cat interrupted
meow life iron monkey
bird person master show with bird and
david
literal cobra kai past rogan
gong hit bug snacks the claw shank
redemption
snow leopard patrol grumpy cat
jonathan skywalker and ancient mutant
ninja turtle
school of block fist of furry
little trouble and big panda the fat and
the furious five
there are no accidents there
are no accidents there are no accidents
spoken like an old man who craps his
pants
uh danielle you did also point out that
this is uh
this has a lot of last dragon parallels
uh
it does have a lot of last are you
really gonna let me okay fine i'm taking
it
you have the floor i can't talk about
last dragon on the show i'm very excited
um so it does the thing where it's like
the the kid who is looking for a master
who doesn't wind up existing and it
turns out that the power was in them all
along where it's like with with uh
uh bruce lee roy he had like that kind
of necklace thing
and then this they've got the dragon
squirrel plus someone does actually glow
they get the glow in the end
um just tai long uh so the whole time
i'm like
i really want to make all these
parallels to last dragon but those are
jokes that are just for me
do i have time uh and i had enough time
to do enough to tell spencer like
we can't do it but i just need this
acknowledgement i think we need to save
them
should we ever do raya in the last
dragon and just let's just accidentally
open oh
we jumbled the two of uh dvds together
and we accepted the last dragon instead
it's like oops all dragons we just
barry gordy's raya and the last dragon
give it to me put it right in me
uh what else we got um we got some
questions
um let's see uh miss orsa asks
what actor who usually plays a hero
would you like to see playing a villain
mine is meg ryan hm oh
okay i could see evil meg yeah who do
you think could go like totally
heel turn and like you'd be like no not
them
so this might be because she's an
actress that you see in a lot of stuff
but you mostly know her for her i think
uh um nicole buyer would
be really funny to see as a villain just
because like unnailed it she's so
supportive and
she's really funny and all of her other
stuff so just watch her go like complete
you know wackadoo villain that could be
kind of fun yeah
i know this one's kind of like life
imitating art or or whatever
cause like you know she's being revealed
as a villain or or is
gaining a reputation as a villain but
like her still her on-screen persona is
like so nice
that like ellen degeneres should just
embrace it and just
play like an absolute terror in some in
some movie like
just be like f it i'm the villain now
and i think that would be fantastic and
people would like
come around and just just like
appreciate that uh
yeah again taking your l's in public
that's lovely yes
uh let's see james bond s if china was
to do an american set animated movie
like kung fu panda
what form of combat and animal would it
be mma eagle
god i i would love to see china's take
on like
we're doing an american culture movie
like 2003 america um which of course
would be ufc
and the animal would probably have to be
a
god like a like a one of those like
super pigs that like they
like they pump full of hormones like
have you seen that photo of the
the pig that uh pooped on its own balls
yes i've seen it often
i think that would be that pig that pig
would do mma
wearing oh gosh wearing like a trucker
hat yeah
yeah so uh uh pig poop balls mma
[Laughter]
from the makers of uh not of kung fu
panda but from then he has to find
the chinese government a romance or mrs
pig poop balls
um ben zeitenas in honor quotes
of coming to america could you make an
unnecessary sequel on his trailer just
cram them all into one
they don't deserve more that's uh that's
a little harsh to coming to america we
talked about that on sju yesterday
is it necessary no few movies are
especially sequels
but i think that it doesn't deserve to
be
in the same breath as zoolander 2
or dumb and dumber 2 which we have done
it on his trailer for so check out the
one for dumb and number 2 is one of the
saddest weeks of my life
oh sorry spin i mean that's my favorite
like comedy of that era i think of like
like fairly brothers not shallow hell
um but dumb and dumber dumb and dumber
is uh
is probably my favorite like jim carrey
movie so so yeah that was tough to watch
next friday for me was like oh that's
not
yeah but that is a good idea to do uh
because they all have a lot in common
uh so the unnecessary uh sequel on his
trailer we could we could get around to
that
yeah um after years of decline jim one
asked
do you think dreamworks is having a
comeback with the success of the croods
and trolls world tour
trolls world tour was dreamworks what
was it perhaps
uh i'm gonna look that up uh and his
dreamworks making a comeback i don't you
know i
don't dreamworks movies are so kind of
like
i don't want to say forgettable because
obviously if you named them i would
recognize them and they
they have had big hits but they're
really like the fast food of animated
movies it's like
satisfying cheating they go down easy
you don't think about it later unless
something's gone horribly wrong
yeah and like chose world tour obviously
um
might have an asterisk we won't know how
it could have performed had we all been
allowed outside
so we don't know but uh yeah you know
they're
they're they're all perfectly fine
movies um
i i don't hate them they're just kind of
there and then yeah like you said it's
like a good sandwich like it was really
yummy but it's tuna fish i can get it
anywhere yep
yeah and that boss baby man that boss
baby keeps getting into trouble
uh always you can't keep that boss baby
out of trouble yeah
uh okay final uh question from rob
turner uh
pitch a film blank comedian plays blank
animal
in blank oh geez
um i wouldn't even know
uh dane cook plays
um he plays a viper in
um what was that thing that he i'm not
going to do it on here because i think
it's too close to flicking people off
but what was that
the super finger yeah right in super
finger
maybe not a viper because you'd have to
have hands yeah
like some kind of like cool that's that
that's the closing dog yeah oh
he needs to learn to flick people off um
super finger uh
i will go with eric andre plays
an ostrich in your mom
that's it that's my pitch
erica plays the ostrich in your mom
that's my
that's my mad libs uh animal thing so
okay so uh the the t's for next week
you got last week so look back to that
week so today will be the tease for kung
fu panda
which is something like um
um yeah you're gonna
you're gonna be uh we're gonna really be
pandering for next week's honest trailer
and that's your clue thank you danielle
for joining me
uh once again always a pleasure and
thank you guys for watching so much on
yet another week of honest trailers
commentary we'll be back tomorrow with
sgu back throughout the week with more
stuff and we'll see you then
[Music]
bye
you